foreign
[Music]
[Music]
two minutes and two seconds that's a new
record everyone
[Applause]
you gotta Stop scaring the new guys off
I'm leaving for the summer and I need
someone to replace me if only there were
a fine young gentleman with your last
name why do you guys keep insisting that
I hire my son he knows the secret of
this place a night guard I'll just mess
it up when have you ever messed anything
up
everybody yeah
want me to unwrap it for you that
wouldn't be necessary Nicholas I am a
master Swordsman
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe you could just rip the corner a
little just one more thing don't forget
to lock the basement the basement
oh no this is bad this is very very very
very
have returned to rule the world
which is going to have to wait a sec
because my foot's asleep
the god of Chaos hey shouldn't you have
a scarier name like okay Seth works
grab my hand that's your hand oh
it should be smooth sailing from here
looks like this place is booby trapped
get me out of
it get me out of here please this is how
we say it like a big boy
I'm just a stupid kid who's in way over
his head when I was 18 I led the French
Army to victory over the English I was
only 14 when I led the Lewis and Clark
expedition and law discovered fire when
he was 11.
I know the feeling
[Music]